last night's school board meeting
focused on school violence across the
valley there's been recent fights filmed
and then posted to social media more and
more people saying we need change now
some say a lack of security on campuses
is really a big component of that
madison kimbrough is live from ccsd
headquarters with what some say needs to
be done to keep students and staff safe
madison
from bringing possible weapons to school
to group fights on campus desert oasis
high school was on lockdown twice this
week and last night's board meeting many
parents and teachers expressing the need
for change
there's so much violence in the school
system among the kids among the kids
attacking the teachers or the kids
constantly beating up on each other and
the police are trying to do what they
can but they can't do everything the
community and school leaders calling for
an increase in school security and
student discipline at thursday's board
meeting tommy burns a police and
security consultant has been watching
what's been going on in schools and he
agrees security desperately needs to be
ramped up i think the school district
needs to look at putting more
school police officers on these campuses
which means they're going to have to up
their staffing because obviously there's
a problem incidents at desert oasis high
school being one of them just this week
the high school was put on lockdown
twice for both violent behavior on
campus and a possible weapon at school
even if they have to mix in some
security with that in other words
private security with school police to
try to head off some of this some of the
problems they're having and retired ccsd
police officer fred hutchison who is
also a parent says he'd like to see more
security devices installed to keep
intruders away there was enough cameras
i thought if we had more cameras more
visibility to look down hallways someone
monitoring those cameras because there's
no one monitoring those cameras they're
just recording things coming and going
off the campuses securing the outer
perimeter doors maybe even putting
alarms on the doors
and three weeks ago eight news now
obtained a report from ccsd that there
had been over 5000 violent incidents
reported this school year we just got
updated numbers and it turns out it's
over 6 000 reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now